[Music] do
so [Music] [Applause]
so we have five film profiles and lots for
sony cameras i also have a surprise for you
so stick till the end to find what it is first
off this video will be a brief introduction
to the profiles showing all the settings i've
used and sample footage for each if you're
interested in a more technical comparison
let me know in the comments and i'll make
a different video for that okay let's get
started i'll start with one of my favorite
profiles vectro 100 which initially was made
for street photography having rich and deep
colors with punchy contrast compared his profile
to velvia film simulation or kodak portra
160.
this profile is good out of the camera and
requires no color grading i find using it
in most situations even in low light but since
it's so contrasty you will have to bring up
the iso quite a bit if you don't mind the
noise you'll love the results it gives at
night [Music] the next profile is actually
my favorite profile for portraits and it's
called senova light [Music]
[Music]
softer contrast than vectro 100 with more
pink desaturated tones i believe this is the
perfect profile for skin tone i really do
love the saturated vintage look it has to
it and i don't find the need to color create
this profile at all [Music]
even with a detail level down to seven on
all profiles i still find the sony footage
just a little bit too sharp so for basic correction
and davinci resolve i just bring down the
mid tone sharpness and add some film noise
if you only do these steps you'll notice it
will get rid of all the digital sharpening
and make it look better and even more filmic
[Music]
[Music] the next profile is fuji 400 the fuji
400 gives a beautiful balance between colors
and tones with muted blacks red shifted towards
orange toned down greens and blue shifted
towards magenta it really does give a dreamy
color palette besides the sharpening and adding
some film grain i don't feel like color grading
this profile either because of the beautiful
colors that it gives out of the camera
[Music]
it's really hard to choose a favorite from
all these profiles because each of them has
unique features but if i would have to choose
only one profile for any situation it would
be eve pro plus
with the best noise ratio with soft creamy
gradations from shadows to highlight this
profile is my absolute favorite which made
me use it confidently for ninety percent of
my work i cannot praise this gamma curve enough
cine 1 has 109 output which means you can
easily recover burn highlights also as the
cine gamma with the lowest contrast which
gives you more flexibility in post i have
saved a daytime version and a nighttime version
with lower contrast for really dark scenarios
the night version can be used even daytime
for more latitude in post [Applause] this
profile is my first choice for any project
because i know i can trust the results it
gives me and can easily be further color graded
in post
the next profile is definitely the most artistic
profile and will give you the closest look
to film bluish greens and the saturated tones
with crushed shadows and highlights this is
the perfect filmic profile the second profile
with the best skin tonalities giving a neutral
mute color it will make everything look more
interesting definitely one of my favorites
with a very specific look it can be used in
various situations from street to portrait
nature and sometimes even product commercial
[Applause] generally with sony i recommend
shooting 500 to 1000 kelvin below normal because
i find sony sensors just a tad warmer than
other camera brands maybe also add a little
shift towards cyan or green in the color filter
[Music] [Applause] [Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Music] so here we are at the end as i promised
i have a surprise for you we have three more
picture profiles that i want to share with
you the first profile is made after portrait
800.
leave the color grading behind and get the
most dynamic range out of the camera because
this profile has a super soft contrast and
increased saturation giving you a candy look
just like portra it has the most dynamic range
this camera has to offer and the base iso
starts at 800.
so this profile gets rid of all the nasty
green hues in the skin tones most sony users
are experiencing with s-log and it's pretty
much good to go out of the box depending on
preferences you might want to bring down the
shadows a little to increase the contrast
the next profile is called kodak gold i want
this profile to really give you a golden look
offering the richest yellow and red from all
profiles and requires no grading like i said
i shoot 500 to 1000 kelvin below correct temperature
but only with this profile i recommend bringing
up the kelvin or the color filter towards
yellow or red to emphasize even more the warmer
tones [Music]
the last profile is called cine steel 50d
this profile is going to give you really interesting
color rendition with earthy skin tones and
velvety blues it really does stand out for
the name filmic profile so here you have them
these are the film profiles i've developed
over the past year i know there is a lot of
misinformation about sony colors and we don't
really know how to set the camera because
it can be overwhelming when you have so many
options i really wanted to share my knowledge
with you so it's easier to get good colors
out of the camera these simulations are good
days and can be used straight out of the camera
but i believe you can always get more out
of your footage if you continue post-processing
that's why i still recommend some color grading
and i prepared some luts for you to get even
closer to the film look if you want to see
a one-on-one comparison video besides the
profiles just let me know in the comments
and i'll come back with a detailed video don't
forget to subscribe if you want to be notified
about the video hit the like button or buy
me a coffee if you appreciate the content
until next time happy holidays and have a
good one see ya [Music]
thank you [Music]